hello am i live yet maybe hello hello
hello hello hi welcome to the Demian
explained live stream I am in a new
location for a number of reasons that
I'll get to in just a little bit but
just don't pay attention any the
[ __ ] that I have to say because I
got a get it I wrote notes I wrote notes
like I actually wrote notes down for the
sake of this one here so that I could be
as concise as possible number one once
this for everybody that's watching this
in the future I'm gonna be talking to
the future right now so hello everybody
that's watching here but I'm gonna be
talking to the future for people that
watching in the future I have a few
bullet points of different categories so
if you want things to be in a nice
organized fashion I'm gonna put like
timestamps in the description after we
get done with this stream so that you
can go through and you can get all the
answers in the sections that you
actually want to know about number two
yes I'm in a new location I'm in Austin
for those watching this that have N no
idea where I am or why I've been gone
for so long and videos have been super
sporadic I am in Austin filming another
project it seems like these days I'm
working on project after project after
project and it's true I am and I'm
enjoying it quite a lot
so I'll explain more about that after I
get done with the stream but the main
point of this one is to talk about
Damian if you have not watched Damian
yet there's obviously gonna be spoilers
we're gonna kind of watch it together
here so just uh thank you guys so much
for joining me on this one but this is
gonna explain Damian in all the note'
goodness that I've got over here but the
first note that I have right here most
importantly is a big thank you to act
para games they were linked in the
description of Damian's so if you saw
them they're akka para games they're a
game development company they actually
made a game that I played I think it was
called risk of rain it was about that
adorable little creature in a black and
white world I think they they made that
one unless I'm horribly
[Laughter]
everybody back up I might might be an
idiot here hang out oh oh no no it's a
rain world rainbow it's not risk of rain
risk of Rands the other one rain world I
had the right concept the wrong game I
listen I was talking about the I love
these guys they're so good
rain world is the one there it's a
delightful game it's a slug cat I didn't
goof
all right there's gonna be the time
stamp where I say this is where mark
[ __ ] up this is right here he [ __ ]
up right here but it was made by
occupier games and I just can't thank
them enough for putting so much passion
and art into this project like it was it
was just wonderful what they managed to
do and I'm so grateful that they were
able to pull it off so well so with that
being said I want to bring up some some
concept art and stuff like that I want
to talk about the process of how this
idea came to be and and one of my
favorite things that they've made is
like this I don't know if it's gonna
completely break everything cuz there's
gonna be okay there's gonna be like a
little tunnelling loop of no I don't
think there will be I think it'll be
fine okay so ignore ignore a chat there
right now I I'm only on one monitor
right now I'm trying to do multiple
monitors so everybody ignore everything
that else listen this is not a
professional I guess I could just full
screen this and this oh yeah that
answers that that okay that solves the
problem okay menacing music leg done
thought I don't Donna Donna there's
something about that smile somewhat like
me on the meme like it's all started
with that smile that damn smile just
like that is so it's something so
cute and so surreal about that
particular smile I'm sorry this is that
award-winning smile yeah that okay but
this is the concept art for or sorry
this is the concept art for for what
we've got going on here I don't know how
to make this better I don't know and I
can't all right whatever anyway so the
concept art here is representative of
the actor so we kind of played around
with concepts of like how he was gonna
you look so like I wanted to really
convey the idea that you know he had
taken over Damian's body but he was
still wearing like the same type of
clothing it's just like a color palette
cuz Damian the last time we saw him was
in a tuxedo and it was like a black
tuxedo you know pretty standard but you
know if if we're gonna take him from his
red robe and his white kerchief or
whatever that was we're just gonna
transplant him over here so that was
kind of like the concept to really like
embody how this character was gonna come
across because one of the biggest
challenges with making animation just
like everything has to be conjured up
from scratch everything has to be
thought up from scratch exactly how it's
gonna look how it's gonna come across
and in the end you know the the
characters they really came to life but
uh you know when it comes down to like
the concept like you really have to kind
of like feel it out and then we have to
transfer it how you're gonna make this
style repeat it cross I love this this
like snowy version of Selene cuz you
just look so deadly and just ready to
kill somebody it's it's just super cool
right there but you know like kind of
the the idea of the main colors and
stuff like this it's kind of like any
tumblr mood board or something like this
and here's our boy of a scruffy haired
scruffy haired dude
so yeah I with this I really wanted to
give like Damian like transfer a lot of
his personality that came out of his
costume in who killed markiplier and
tried to translate it into something
that would exist in a winter theme and
you know you
your snowy version there we actually
didn't end up really having a lot of
like snowy details about it because it
was never actually like actively snowing
until the run into the lake but yes sir
so we kind of had the we kind of had a
lot to play around with and this was all
dis communication from Alka power games
like they they were really the spearhead
behind it and they were they're doing so
much work and just translating these
ideas that I had into tangible concepts
for the project itself and in addition
to thanking acaba games I really want to
thank the members of this channel and if
you don't know what that means or what
that is at all I just want to give a big
shout out to everyone that has decided
to support the channel through the
YouTube's built-in membership thing like
you guys talking live in Chad just thank
you guys so much because when I set out
to like have this membership system it
was originally sponsors back in July of
last year but just like just when I when
I put it out there I really wanted to
express the idea that this membership
was gonna go directly towards funding
big projects like this this this
animation as a whole is by far the most
expensive project that I've made and
just to talk about like the timeline of
when this one was made it was I wrote
this I think before Wilford
mother-loving Moore's - or at least I
had the core idea before Wilford
mother-loving Moore's task was ever a
thing maybe it was after maybe I wrote
it after I can't quite remember it might
have been after but it was pretty close
so they were written pretty pretty close
together because I wanted to tell the
story of I wanted to basically wrap up
the story of who killed markiplier so
just a big big big thank you to all the
members who have decided to generously
contribute to allowing me to try to
explore these creative endeavors I
learned so much about making something
working with another team doing audio
engineering I learned so much just in a
very short span of time even though it
took a long time for this to come out
because I I wrote this back in August
and I meant for it
come out in winter hence the winter
theming it's all cold and here we are in
May just a little a little bit late but
that's okay but just um thank you
sincerely to all of the members who have
decided to support and if you want to
help me make cool stuff like this not
even just specifically like this but any
sort of big project that I can like
really sink my teeth into and really
like create and craft and try to do
something that pushes beyond just
standard gaming videos please consider
joining the channel like becoming a
member there's a big join button down
there and if you can press that it'll
show you some perks we do a weekly
livestream I haven't done it over the
past three weeks because I've been so
busy and over here in Austin which I can
talk about later but please do consider
supporting the channel it really does
help me make these things a reality now
on to Damian itself so I want to show
you first and foremost Damian as it
exists in in the project itself so this
is my premiere nightmare of a project
that is 21 layers of audio I have I kind
of had an organizational system to this
initially but then it kind of got chaos
as things changed and I and some things
required a lot of sound effects some
things required like a little bit of
sound effects this I sunk just me
probably close to the hundred plus hours
into just just doing the basic audio
that's not including the the rewrites
the actual writing the the working
through the concept bar just the audio
had to have like this level of detail
into it and I could have made this more
efficient because there are some like
layers that I initially set out to well
thank you blaze lay that originally set
out to have
like come across as this is dialogue
this is it but then I'm an idiot and I'm
scatterbrained and I was working on this
through a long such a long period of
time that things kind of got all over
the place so I won't go through the full
thing in in super fine detail here I
want to turn over and actually watch
through and go through the story beats
but just to talk about like me learning
things number one musical mixing I'm not
the greatest at that I like I I'm not
the greatest making music and really
like a lot of the musical work I do is
just finding stuff on royalty-free sites
and stitching it together well I for
this one I kind of mix and match
different pieces of music and ambience
to try to create like more of a
soundscape
because like this initial opening piece
like here with the like that I I knew I
really wanted something that was gonna
really like punch in the beginning
because I wanted this to be like a more
scary like video like if I was gonna
make a video about Damien and like the
transition to dark applier like I wanted
it to be scary and I wanted it to be
something that was actually like really
honestly horror themed and so when it
comes across I I this is um this is a
single stem of a bigger song I don't
even remember what the full song is
because I only pulled this part out of
it but it's like having this link this
guitar or whatever it is just like
really like whaling in this slow tempo
like just it works so perfectly
especially for just look back
like that yeah it was just so cool
like and and I could not do it but here
comes the big the big issue okay like
look me in the eye
pay attention everybody hey stop what
you're doing drop your pencils imagine
just imagine ask yourself everyone hold
on just imagine ask yourself really ask
yourself what is a tree falling down
sound like really really ask yourself
what does a tree falling down sound like
this isn't a trick this isn't like what
is the sound of one hand clapping what
it sounded like
what does a tree I'm falling down sound
like you know I'll help you out because
I'm gonna go like tree falling down
clunk no I'm not asking for you to
actually spell out what trees falling
down sound like no not move not one not
step nah boom not flop no that's not no
okay that's not you're close but you're
not quite there it really it's it's not
it's just oh yeah that's what I like oh
yeah that's what I want what is this
that's it that's what a tree falling
down sounds like okay now to go back to
my tree falling down sound effect now to
go back to my my trees falling down
sound effect it sounds a lot more like
this let me actually isolate it just get
the music out of there
so I really ignore the food so what what
I really wanted like and what I learned
what I learned is like when when it
comes down to movie sound effects in
like cinematic stuff you know things
never sound like what they actually
sound like you've got this which is a
mixture of like a bajillion different
sounds compare that to which sounds like
a tree falling down it certainly does
but it doesn't have like this oomph to
it and so like part of this process and
part of riot why it took so long is just
because like I wanted I really wanted
this this stuff to come out so like
you've got what is this oh I think it's
like a stick hitting like a metal tin
with dirt on it or something like that
and then you've got this like cuz it's
cold I want there to be like ice and
snow there's like this like ice cracking
and and like this ice cracking and
breaking it's it's a combination sound
and then you've got like wood wood
snapping and then wood hitting a wood
pile I want to get that earthy sound in
there you got bought it it had to
transition from starting to sound far
off so this is like an actual tree
falling yeah that's an actual tree
falling so that's part that's that
what's really built the sound out there
and then you've got this which is just
like by itself it's just long yeah it's
Kabong this is wind wind more sounds you
can see how my organizational structure
went out the window cuz I was like all
right five audio layers for sound
effects that'll be fine that'll be way
more so I'll keep the ambiance down here
and then I'll keep it all up in here and
then I just kept building out here and
so also like I wanted this this bass
sound to really Rumble out and and come
across and be like
mmm-hmm all that is like it's a it's a
it's a ramping slowdown that I edited if
some deep bass I think a guitar like
scratching along a line so I had to I
got that sound and I stretched it and I
did that every single one of these
sounds I hated individually I didn't
make the sounds myself but you can
imagine when it comes to a 20-minute
project that's this huge that's this
huge that's this huge I every single one
of those green boxes in there I had to
individually open up in a separate piece
of software and edit and tweak until it
sounded right and then I just adjusted
the volume and here I added some effects
in here like for equalization to make it
make it sound different over there and
just like all this different layers of
stuff to make a tree fall down
and I got faster as as things went on
like I got I got a lot faster as things
went on but you know that that's kind of
like the process behind the whole thing
is and my part my contribution to this
it was like aside from voicing it like I
I assembled all this together I like I I
directed it and I picked these shots and
I wanted to really give an oomph to it
and and it's it's not like I said like
all the stuff that I do this is not
perfect so it's it's just like layering
layering layering layering so if you're
ever trying to get to a point where
you're like oh this doesn't sound right
if you're trying to make something
that's not a fart joke in a YouTube
video you know like layer it layering is
a big key of everything filling out the
space of sound imagining what things
could sound like and then like bring
that to life deeper like a lot of my god
the the the part in the middle when like
your gears going on to the you're going
on to the to the lake here and like just
with the like trying to trying to get
the right sound of of steps because
these are the steps layered on top of
this which is snow steps so so together
they kind of fill out like just some
some movement of the feet some extra
sounds coming in like to get this like
kind of crunch on ice cuz there was like
there's like there's like ice skates on
ice that was like the only sound effect
I could really sound or find and it's
like clack clack clack clack it sounded
really weird I did use it known we're
not recording anything I I did use it
this that's my dialogue I think it was
here oh yeah that that's like that's
like an actual skating but just the
amount of like sound just like that to
try to pump into this thing so really
hard
and the deep rumbles the music trying to
balance all that and this amazing shot
that they that occupier made like this
oh man this is like the coolest shot in
the whole frickin video just like it's
so well done and just like the beauty of
this idea and I cuz I had this idea and
I basically just wrote it down in words
and they just brought it to life and
it's it what that is is like it's the
it's the amazing of having really
talented people that really know what
they're doing and just talking it over
and over and over again being like yes
this this this this this this kind of
describing it and so like I learned a
lot more about just like getting my
point across getting like what I want
out like really like getting things down
to the nitty gritty details because
there's a lot of times when you're
making something and you can tell it to
somebody but it doesn't always work out
doesn't always work out because people
will misunderstand what you want if
you're not communicating enough so like
that's just another part of learning and
all the previews basically came from
this one part here
and this was just me trying to like
really really like embody this like
transition like the worlds shifting out
from under them I'll get into more
detail about what what everything means
and stuff like that but just to to to
really appreciate it like I want you
guys to understand that like this was
this is hard like it's it's just it's
just really hard and that's why I'm so
unbelievably proud of how it turned out
and I'm and I'm so unbelievably proud of
the work that akka Parra put into it and
and that's why I like I want you guys to
know like with with these these projects
like I take them very seriously and I
and I take them very like very very
seriously I guess but I mean like I
treat him with the respect that they
deserve because I don't want to do
anything that you know that I that I
don't know how to do properly and and if
I when I wrote this idea I was like I
don't think that this is something that
I could film like it didn't seem like
something that was gonna be feasible to
film I I think when I first wrote it
wrote it there was I had this idea that
it was gonna be more like a radio drama
that was enhanced by art like just a
little bit and then I and then I saw
like these cinematic like cinematics for
world of warcraft like the I forget
which one it was but there was one yeah
it was the war bringers cinematics so
like these these ones I can't play it or
else okapi strike super hard but you you
guys the war bring is one of the ones
that were like painted kind of in the
style that I had there I liked that
element of storytelling the more
animatic one it's not full full
animation but it's it's it's still
animation in its core it's still able to
convey motion and tell a story and
really like show something progress
through time and like it's just really
cool oh so thank you everybody that's so
much that
is joining as a member like really thank
you guys so much it it really means the
world that you guys are willing to
support more stuff like that and like
it's it's just crazy to see like how far
this come I I'm in Austin and I'm
working on for those of you don't know
the cats out of the bag a project called
a heist with markiplier supposed to be a
kind of like continuation it's an
interactive story I like I can't give
too many details about it but I I sat
down and I was in I was in I was in the
office with roosterteeth I'm working on
it with roosterteeth and I was just
sitting there and I was like we were
shot listing and I stopped and I was
like I remember a long time ago I
remember a long time ago when I first
wanted to do YouTube and I was like I
want to make sketch videos I want to
make sketch videos I want to I want to
make like little short films I want to
do that and I didn't even know how to
hold a camera I didn't even know the
difference between a camcorder and a
DSLR when it came to shooting video I
didn't know about sensor sizes like ISO
like any of that stuff I didn't know the
first thing about an f-stop I didn't
know how to compose a shot I didn't know
about like how continuity worked I
didn't know how to carry a story through
and like Here I am seven years later
literally breaking down every single
shot of this huge sprawling interactive
story and you know I I just kind of
stopped and I was like I have so much
knowledge in my head and it's like I
don't know where one point it ever came
from and it's just like a continual
journey for seven years that I've been
trying to improve myself and I've been
trying to get better at what I do and
have been trying to showcase my talents
to the world whatever those talents may
be and I just I kind of stopped and I
was just like this is really cool you
know this is really really cool
and yeah I just really grateful that you
guys believed in me enough to allow me
to show you guys what I can do so anyway
all that being said I do want to turn
you guys attention to two different
projects that I kept our games made
themselves they linked them on their
Twitter they're two different
behind-the-scenes videos that they made
and one is behind the scenes of the
characters that were made and the other
is a behind the scenes of of the
after-effects how the after-effects
really came about and how they how they
were able to transform these ideas and
like the motion of of these different
scenes and how they were able to turn
them into actual animatics and like it
to get that the they'll like colors to
flow and stuff like that
and you can see like if you think the
audio that I was working on was like
intense just imagine what it was like
for the the entire team drawing every
single thing like like and they didn't
even have to drop everything this link
these these characters were actually
like 3d models like these were 3d models
that they that they had they they kind
of made a base model out of the concept
art so that we compose them and then
they hand painted over the models
themselves to make them feel like art to
give them more personality oh man the
storyboards like the storyboard artist
was great like with what he was able to
do and and just like how he was really
like the key to transform these these
ideas into what like what we really
wanted so like you you have the art and
then then it goes to the painting
process so you can see how the initial
posed from the 3d model is used as a
base for eventually the art which which
like also goes over it seems weird to
say like they had a 3d model and then
they painted over it in anyway why
wouldn't they just paint it from the
start it is infinitely easier to work
from a model and have a base structure
and like the character be there and then
add details in hand pain
than it is to just hand paid everything
from from the get-go that's that's why
that was done that way okay so with all
that being said those links I'll put
them in the description as well
afterwards I don't think I put them in
before but they are over at a Kapaa res
YouTube which is just a couple games you
can go check it out over there and then
that's where you can see all that it's
not rotoscoped because the 3d models
themselves can be placed with no
backgrounds so they can have
transparency so they don't need a
rotoscope anything and they build the
background separately some of them are
hand painted some of them are 3d so like
it's it's a mixture of a lot of
different arts you got the 3d modeling
you've got the the painting the over it
the effects and After Effects
transforming and bringing it to life
using these Photoshop files in After
Effects to really get the layers to like
pop and move and stuff like that so go
to acabar games on YouTube and look for
the links if you're watching this in the
future in the description down there to
check out these videos if you want to
know more about how exactly this was
made now what we're gonna do is we are
gonna do what we've done for the past
few projects and we're gonna go step by
step of Damien we're gonna watch it
through and I'm going to basically give
commentary and explain it as we go
through it and then after we watch
through it we will talk about exactly
like all all the answers to all the
questions I want to answer all the
questions basically so without further
ado we will begin momentarily one second
one second make sure something's all
righteously good here there we go No
yeah that's good enough they're good
enough that's probably good enough I
don't know whatever it doesn't matter
okay so without further ado oh god no
but that's fine that's fine that's fine
oh yeah that's fine Oh that'll do
that'll do without further ado here we
go
and as you know what actually we did it
half speed before but I just cuz I love
the video so much what I'm just gonna
watch it at full speed it's another
watching party hehehe it was so fun to
see you guys's live reaction to this -
it was the first time that we did a it
was the first time that I've done a few
premieres before it but it was the first
time that I did a premiere and I was
really excited to see you guys as
responses to it as it was happening that
was just that was just it was it was it
was amazing like like amy was watching I
was watching we were both on separate
computers so we could lik look at chat
and I was chatting and just like good
stuff okay anyway so let's go
[Music]
okay so just to break down that first
segment and what what I really wanted to
convey a lot of people picked up on this
but you know I just this show just uh to
show I released a video nine months ago
nine months ago called go back to sleep
I released it like midnight and a lot of
people will see and they they're like oh
these are parallels and and basically
yeah you're right these these these are
parallels because you can see like the
opening shot of Damian from this and
what I'm trying to what I what I wanted
to do with this this just shows how long
ago I wanted to make this this was in
August of last year I made this because
I wanted to make Damian this is like my
this was like my lookbook for Damian for
akha para to take and be like this is
the mood I want I made this like it late
at night just because I really wanted to
do this but yeah this is how long ago I
wanted to make this and and like there's
a lot of themes here that tie into a lot
of other things I was connecting like
the last shot of Damian like with Celine
there that that's what that's all about
you know just generic stuff like it's
the winter landscape you know the old
wooden barn dad cabin whatever you want
to call it and like the concept of like
go back to sleep and stuff like that
like it really plays out in in Damian in
such a cool way and yeah it's just like
what the most frustrating part about
things like this and realizing that when
you have to work with other people who
can do things that I cannot it takes
time it takes a lot of time a lot of
time nine months of work to plan out
this and try to get this going and and
all of this also like offshoots of this
kind of idea that I was I was bringing
up after who killed markiplier came out
you know I wanted to make one thing to
really finish off the whole storyline
with that and I'll get into more details
about that later but just like I really
want something that was gonna set the
mood and I feel like the first minute of
Damian is just part of like the coolest
the coolest opening sequence I could
have possibly hoped for but anyway
so the next is like setting the
environment you you get like the opening
like an establishing shot and then you
get the environment this long journey
back carrying wood an indeterminate
distance and I wanted to really like let
this play like this is just how far
Demian went every day every day Damien
had to go to this freaking far just to
get wood and like it's this long long
journey it's like this isn't even
conveying how long it really is like
it's it's a long walk and like you can
see that in in the last shot because in
the in the last job when it's sweeping
over the hills like there's so yes like
he just has to cut farther and farther
down but yeah and then like getting
Saleem back in here really like having
Saleem be this like Saleem like not
having a speaking introduction into this
just like being there as an observer
just watching like like just leering
over a Damien's words sitting there and
waiting for him to come back like I just
wanted to show that dog slam the door
don't slam the door okay so yeah with
with like that journey with that journey
yeah destroying the environment yeah
that's pretty much what who was it yeah
yeah because she has a job to do while
he's resting yeah don't slam the door at
the damn door the door so what what I
what I really wanted to do about this
and I'm going out of order for my from
my notes but I wanted to flesh out
Saleem as a character because Saleem and
who killed mark pliers it was a very
unknown one of the things that I want
you guys to know is that I am NOT a
perfect writer I'm not a great writer I
am better than I was but if I'm just now
getting decent two years ago I was not a
perfect writer so when Saleem was
introduced Saleem was not a perfect
character
because she her motivations were unknown
and and I'm okay with like a sense of
mystery but if a characters motivations
are unknown and then never determined
that's not good writing like because
then you have no idea it's such an
open-ended thing and so all of the ideas
of like don't trust the seer don't make
any sense because you don't know what
the seer wants or who this year is or
like who like the seer like represents
in this story so when I when I wanted to
tell this story it I had this idea that
I wanted to make Damien and Celine
brother and sister and and because it
made sense like there was a resemblance
and like canonically I just wanted that
to be the case and also adding that
layer really made Selena's character a
lot more robust a made it so that she
had something to care for and it made
her motivations very known like she's
she's there to protect her brother and
like that's her big overarching
motivation in this and so like this
opening dialogue I needed to I needed to
have it play out in like this quiet way
to number one show that like you know
Damien has a job to do and it's a very
simple job but he mentions something
that's different than in here and I'll
sled play my soft flower today or
there's still a few more weeks of winter
left and that flower will die cold and
alone or that either way winter can't
last forever Celine with any luck we'll
be able to get out of this cabin soon
luck doesn't keep the fire going luck
won't change the weather
and luck definitely won't put food on
the table well I mean if you think about
it you probably do need some luck and
finding something to eat in the middle
of winter out of snow good luck whatever
try not to burn the cabin down while I'm
out
did you really see a flower yes a little
pink one
so I think
probably dead by now get some sleep you
look tired
so um with this like a mostly like I I
wanted a right dialogue that was number
one to establish how their relationship
work together like Celine's nature of
being like this overprotective like
controlling older sibling like very
typical but also you know they they have
a nice dynamic and I wanted them to be
you know friendly and and I also wanted
to showcase that this flower is not
normal because you know no one at this
point knows that like things are looping
over and over again no one knows that
but that's why Selena stops at the door
casein is like did you really see a
flower because I just wanted to show
that like this was something this is
anomaly and originally like this script
was a lot longer but with animation and
like costs of animation I I paired it
down it was a really gonna be like 30
minutes or something like that and then
I had to squish it down like a lot of
the lot of the ideas are just like
really squished in there just because of
limitations of time and stuff like that
yeah the flower yeah the heck and flower
yeah and a canned flower yeah yeah okay
yeah so like um mom happy Mother's Day
oh yeah
okay so so Damien like suddenly gets
tired like that that's a point like
hee-hee as many of you guys noticed like
he's just on a loop he's in a loop
he's just looping over and over again
he's he's just he can't read he doesn't
realize it you know he thinks his
dialogue was that winter will be over
soon you know and as you guys know when
you've seen this at the end of it like
all those trees that are covering the
hills are representative of like every
day he goes out to cut a tree every tree
stump represents a day the trees just go
on endlessly and endlessly out so he's
been in this place for an unknowable
amount of time living the same exact day
over and over again while Celine watches
over and and goes out at night to
accomplish her business and so like it's
just it's it doesn't matter like how
many days so everyone that's trying to
count the number of trees like that's
not the point
it's just it's all metaphor to try to
showcase that he's stuck in purgatory
like that's the idea of it and so when
he sees his flower like this is the
first thing that's changed and so this
scene originally there were gonna be
three originally there were gonna be
three loops before he goes to the lake
there were three different loops there
and it was slowly building out of those
loops and there was one other middle
scene in there but for the sake of the
story I had to condense it and chop it
out and then input those elements into
other parts of the story and it worked
out
you don't die easily do hello
you went to people
so many people who's there
hello
so with this like the flower everyone's
always debating like what the flower is
what what breed it is it doesn't matter
what breed it is what matters is that
it's pink
like those dialogue that plays out there
they're exact lines from Wilfred
mother-loving war sash and the point
that's trying to convey here's this
flowers the first change in his
environment in anything like the whole
the whole motif is like winter is
turning into spring like as a means of
suggesting that these he's leaving this
purgatory the reason that flower is
there is is is moreover to the fact that
Wharf stash is starting to peel back the
layers that are like covering up this
world and he's starting to crack like
the code of the matrix he's trying to
like get behind that he's starting to
get behind the scenes he's starting to
spread out this this flower it's not a
conscious reach out from Wharf stash to
Damian it is just a result of Wharf
stash actually like coming to terms of
with what's happening and where it's
going time is is very like wishy-washy
in this place like I I wanted to really
convey in the sense that you know time
when it comes to ideas you know there
really is no start and finish to it like
an idea once it exists it has always
existed like I I kind of like wanted to
convey that like once once the idea
comes across for Wharf stash that he's
he's really like starting to come to
terms with who he is and what he's doing
like it echoes beyond that and it can
kind of lead cracks in the world of the
environment itself if like everything is
just this one unified space of like in
the house or in the upside down or
whatever you want to call it then
someone breaking the rules over here
spills out and affects everyone else
who's also in this place because if the
rules changed and then the rules change
for everybody and this is just like a
first clue
of what's happening does that make sense
probably not but all that dialogue is
saying that this is a result of Wars -
it's not a conscious choice of him it's
not him trying to help Damien it is just
a result of that because I wrote this in
Wolford mother-loving Moore's - at about
the same time
- both wrap up this story from the two
angles and end of the two angles of the
two main characters and then really give
them resolutions and use these as
vehicles to answer questions that came
up out of who killed markiplier so
that's what that is
so then he comes back to the cabin and
he's looping again I saw a flower today
or there's still a few more weeks of
winter left and that flower girl died I
heard so the thing that I was most
worried about going from three loops to
two is three is the minimum amount you
need to establish a pattern but with
three like there just was it added like
another five minutes and it was just too
much time in addition to the other
things that I had to cut out so like I
really wanted to convey that right here
this is a you know it's not ideal but
it's like okay because you guys caught
on that like oh there's the loop he's
getting it otherwise I would have put
three there and there were some other
set pieces that I wanted to convey that
that really showed how the world was
breaking before it just went from flower
to suddenly lake you know like that
that's why that feels a little bit like
sudden what there's no one else in these
woods Damian but it sounded far away I
should have followed the voice but it
trailed off and I had to get back with
firewood
plenty of Dameon there is no one else in
these woods if there were I'm sure I
would have run into them by now you're
not getting enough sleep you need to
sleep
are you staying up all I'm out what no
I'm fine I'm not even tired what about
you
what are you tired you're always awake
by the time I get back I'm not a growing
boy like you little brother oh please
you're older by ten minutes which is
just long enough for me to be in charge
so shut up and go to bed
that doesn't make you in charge how does
it make you the boss of me just just be
careful I don't know maybe I'm crazy but
whatever I heard out in those woods it
didn't sound too friendly so just
just be careful I can take care of
myself don't slam the door you always
need to be right sometimes sometimes I
know things okay so let's pause there
for a second so with this one like
something is definitely changing and
that like worries Celine cuz cuz like
she's going out every night to hunt for
actor mark she's not going out there
just to watch guard now she's going to
she's gonna [ __ ] kill him and she's
just gotta find him first so the this
kind of duality between it and and and
like it plays off of the whole thing
that I've been hinting at for [ __ ]
ever the whole the whole go back to
sleep
it's time to wake up like you need to go
to sleep you need to wake up it's this
duality of the two of these characters
having to share like a body like I
wanted to write this as if like what the
[ __ ] is it like for two people to share
like a single life like a body like that
and so the way it plays out is like
Celine made this place for broken things
the broken things is Damien Damien is
the broken thing in this like Celine
made mistakes and who killed markiplier
and that wasn't conveyed properly but
she made mistakes she misjudged what the
actor was capable of and so when push
comes to shove like and and everything
goes wrong the one person that Celine is
gonna try to protect is Damien like
that's that's what she's going to do bar
none cuz cuz like it's the one thing
that's important to her and that's why I
wanted to flesh that out and like really
establish this relationship like it's
the motivation behind it she would do
anything literally anything to protect
her little brother like that's that's
really what I wanted to convey across
that and that point here so when when
she goes out at night and he needs like
you need sleep this is the point the
only reason that Damien is able to stay
alive
in in whatever sense that he is alive
like his spirit or whatever you want to
call like the the only part of him that
is able to stay alive as if he sleeps so
she when she's saying like you're not
getting enough sleep you need to sleep
is like you absolutely need to sleep
while I'm out because that is the only
way that you can stay yourself makes
sense yes
well that's weird what
that wasn't there before
how did I notice this
okay so like I said this was originally
three scenes instead of just the two but
what I wanted to convey is like because
Worf stash is unintentionally breaking
the universe that they're in actor mark
is able to take advantage of that these
are not connected different things it's
not deception on the part of actor mark
for for this to happen that's why you
know they say an improv like why is this
day important this day is important
because the change started now
everything up before this was stagnation
looping over you want to you want to
think about Damien going out to cut wood
every day and perform his useless task
of nothingness Celine's task at night
was her useless task of nothingness of
trying to find the actor and never
succeeding so she also is stucked in a
loop of her own making
cuz silly ins not the master of this
world that they're in she is just able
to do she has power so she has some
control over it she's not like in
control I don't think anybody actually
is in this so it's just a matter of you
know it's it's just a matter of them
both being in purgatory until wharfs -
coming to terms with his own place in
this world and coming to terms with the
things that life has thrown him that
causes things to spiral downwards
this doesn't make sense
is that you
I wanna I wanna I wanna point out real
quick this music let me see if I can
find it this music it's really menacing
it's really cool it's very driving I
like it a lot
but the original music is what was it
the original music is not the original
music is where I know it's in here
somewhere
was it this one this one yeah there's
this one ok so sounds really menacing at
first right oh yeah I'm feeling this
okay this is cool yeah yeah then wait
there's okay
like this flute comes in
and just like totally robbed all the
momentum out of this moment cuz it's
like this really cool driving music oh
yeah oh [ __ ] yeah man
oh yeah and then like us like what [ __ ]
this is such a good piece and then like
later on in the song the song is called
are we being followed by the way and
it's nice part here which I liked like
this is good it's very minute this onee
he's in the lake and it's like I toned
it down a little bit it's a little too
like Elvis like dude and then it gets
back any button you can hear the
clarinet
and so
[Music]
it's just like and it was like it was so
weird like just to be like the choice to
add a flute and like some woodwinds I
got nothin wrong with a flute flute has
its place this piece great without just
like it's just like without the flute it
was really so much better I don't mind a
flute I mean if you play a flute I'm
guessing that you already understand
that you're a nerd like I get it certain
people are gravitates towards dumb
instruments they're not there I get it
that you're not cool enough to be a
trumpet player so you have to be a flute
I get that I understand there are the
type of people that have to endure that
kind of life I would never judge someone
for making the terrible choice of
playing the flute I get that that's fine
and I get it to each their own
- every person is their own person and I
am NOT that person cuz I'm just too
awesome and I play the trumpet so yeah
anyway so but you know that's just where
everything is is a little bit off there
but that's I just wanted to talk about
that for a second longer than I needed
to
Oh also not everyone caught this but you
can see the shadow of a figure in here
like that so that's why he makes the
snap judgment to the feet but some
people are confused to me
yeah so uh yeah it's just um
pretty straightforward this this scene
is just like he's led to believe that
Saleem is in the water the other scene
that was deleted from this and had to be
rewritten was this was gonna be a
progressing thing where the first night
he goes in we except in she's the flower
and then he comes back tell Saleem about
the voice he goes to sleep he wakes up
from the door being blown open so it's
like every every night you can hear
Saleem locks the door locks it in
there's no locks on the inside it's it's
locked from the outside which Damian is
like that's now weird but she locks the
door and so the deleted scene was gonna
have the door blow open and him go
outside and hear Saleem call for help
and so it was gonna be a progressing
thing where he goes out a little bit he
got lost in the storm and he woke up in
the day in bed and Beal and Celine's
there cuz she dragged him in from being
out in the snow and there was gonna be
more dialogue there was a lot of
dialogue that was put into the second
segment with a voice that would have
been put in like in the next loop back
because then it would have been like at
night he woke up and looked in the
mirror and saw that but it's it's fine
this way like it's totally fine the way
it is
huh was there a flat oh yeah this the
flower wind game what is it like right
there yeah it's a flower I didn't write
that in that was added in by the artist
I just thought it'd look cool a lot of
people try to discern meaning out of
every single little nuance of what
happens in anything not everything has a
meaning some things just look cool like
that like this cool it's cool to see I
mean you draw whatever meaning you want
from it like a lot of a lot of a lot of
what I write like it's when I say what I
talked about Wilfred muddled up more
session I was like everything is very
plain there and it is it is very plain
with this it is very similar everything
in this is very plain everyone's like
it's so complicated it's so crazy I've
convoluted the stories like it's it's
really not like the details the nitty
gritty the nuance the minutiae of it
you're too focused on the minutiae of it
all I literally wrote that line because
people are always like but what about
the the vase that was in the living room
and why was it it had a tint of red
maybe some blue in there it's like
you're too focused on the details like
the point of a story is not to get
wrapped up in you know in in all those
tiny little details of of those things
not that the details are unimportant
when telling talking about story but
it's there is a line at which it becomes
bad because then you become over
analytical about things and you you you
you wonder what the meaning of
everything is so you force your own
meaning into it and like then things can
spill out and not make sense what about
the snow though I like the winter theme
it's cool
seems like purgatory seems like
stagnation I like the thing of going
from winter to spring it's just good I
liked it because vases hold flowers
you're very funny very very funny also
this shot like I'm not a hundred percent
sure what this represents but it's
[ __ ] cool right you know what I mean
like this you know people are like just
represents the the souls of the people
the dark applier kills like darker
particle anybody it's just like this is
just [ __ ] cool like sometimes the
cool wins out over anything this is just
this is a great shot it's it's so cool
like I love the whole ideas of demons
faces peering out like and all these
like you know the Damien dead face like
it's so cool it's just [ __ ] cool
sometimes the answer is it's really cool
like really [ __ ] cool
[Music]
so with the voices like I wanted
something to really like fill fill the
space of this I didn't pick anything
specifically because of story beats I
picked things that sounded interesting
like that would be visually engaging the
auditorially engaging the point is that
he's hearing things behind the scenes
you know behind the Korea peering behind
the curtain you you can hear if you're
on a soundstage and you walk down behind
the scenes you'll hear people doing
their scenes and telling their stories
and acting out their stories behind the
difference you're just hearing echoes
these are all echoes just echoes doesn't
mean doesn't mean anything specific but
the this is what I mean when people
focus on the nuances people worry about
what the voices are saying they're not
worried about why you're hearing voices
that should be the question in people's
minds with a lot of like like these
things and not just what I do but in
stories in general it's not about the
details of what the voices are saying
but just stop and ask why are there
voices in the first place that's the
question to really ponder like why would
there be voices here like if people
automatically they skate right over
there like oh yeah there of course there
would be voices in that void that would
make total sense I've been in voids
before and they're always voices just
generally no why why why why why why not
what why not what what did he say
analyze the audience like why that's the
question yeah Damian you are a hard man
to find
who are you we're Saleem now there's a
hard woman to avoid so I want to before
we're going to let this play a little
bit but just preface is about the actor
it is really [ __ ] hard to voice two
different characters in this same
goddamn scene and have them sound at
least remotely different and and I think
I pulled it off pretty well because like
I wanted originally like I was doing
a more like new you think that you could
be and then I was like man that doesn't
sound right
so I thought about what I sounded like
when I first started YouTube you know
hello everybody
markiplier here you know a higher a
higher like timbre to the voice so like
and then I I made him really sing song
like Demian you are a hard man defied
like really sing song again and I think
like it came across really well like I
really loved doing the lines like I
[ __ ] love doing the lines this
because once I got the groove of it I
was like I picked what I wanted that to
be I was like does make sense and then I
was like realizing that Damien was just
like very wooden in his line so I was
like alright let's try to do it then I
redid all of those lines and you know he
was just Nick it was really cool any way
you did anything to her
I'm easy there cowboy I've done nothing
to her I don't even think I could that
woman would carve my heart out and feed
it to me if she even saw me what then
why am I here what do you want from me
Oh Damien oh my poor sweet Damien I've
come to apologize do do I know you
of course you know dare I say you
probably know me as well as you know
yourself sorry bad joke couldn't help
myself I know you
oh come on Damien Selena really did a
number on you didn't she
and circle takes the square took you out
friend but you made all right for those
of you who are wondering this that line
there was so intentional because that is
reference to the nineteen fifties show
Hollywood Squares
and that was specifically meant so you
wouldn't know the exact year that didn't
no not at all I thought it sounded like
what he would say I wanted him to say
something that was kind of like game
show II and show bode like Hollywood II
like act what an actor would say you're
not gonna say like hey you got it right
you know and circle takes his squares
okay I don't know I just thought it
sounded cool and yeah yeah they have
this he and Wilfred have the same line
about how Celine would rip rip their
heart out I really III wrote remember I
wrote these two at the same time I
wanted to really convey from two
different people who are both making a
pot who who both at this this close to
this time in the story were saying
apologies originally this is gonna be
like minute fifty and I think that
happens I'm in like 12 or something of
welfare mother Bolivia more stash
they're both it's it's it's very similar
in the way these two confrontations
happen like with the detective and and
morph stash like they're having a very
similar conversation with with with
Damien and the actor but it's just
they're different people so like these
these these reasonings and these things
happening playing out they happen in in
different ways just because of who they
are like that Wilfred like he's like
like like I'm sorry and just really
[ __ ] actually gives an apology because
he it Emilia's sorry he's a sweetheart
and a murderous psychopath that he is
but it's like he's he's just like he
really apologizes and then the actor
comes there's like I've come to
apologize doesn't ever [ __ ] apologize
like that was intentional like I've come
to apologize and then never ever
apologizes yeah it doesn't make any
sense
we were just at your party and then we
were
whoa there easy boy I'm gonna I also
wanted to be just so [ __ ]
condescending just like whoa easy boy
all right little all right come on Chum
all right kid let's sit down a little
bit you're just being silly I'll be
right there because I just don't have
time for the whole catching other thing
no you need to answer me how did I get
here
we're even Emma whoa okay all right I'll
just summarize and it's best summarized
by saying that mistakes were made plans
weren't exactly properly executed the
right people started pointing fingers at
the wrong people and a good night with
some good friends may have taken a wrong
turn at some point and okay I may have
made a deal to possibly make sure that a
certain lady couldn't go around breaking
anyone else's heart ever again but
that's all in the past what matters now
is moving forward and all how beautiful
the future is gonna be with you so so I
want to point out something this is the
very first conversation you have with
the actor literally think about it the
actor in the entirety of who killed
markiplier only said one line and that
was welcome welcome welcome or he had a
couple lines you know but a one
paragraph of text was all the actor has
ever said up until this point he didn't
say a [ __ ] thing besides it's not
fair is it and it's just like that was
all that's all he said gets tall he
[ __ ] said that's all he said in the
entire scene this is the first time uh
he's talked and and one of the things
that I'm I haven't looked at my nose at
all but one of the things that like I
wanted to put a crosshair it clearly is
something that I said a long time ago
and I still stand by it if something is
not on the screen imply
in some way shape or form it is not true
you can infer truths but alike by trio
que forget I said true is not like is
not inherently proven there we go it's
not proven if it's not on the screen if
it's not said implicitly if it's not
directed in there I firmly believe in a
story it is not provable it's not proven
true that's why I said at the who killed
mark glare like stream two years ago
that when I said I would have liked
Demian a Saleem to be brother and sister
but it was never ever proven on it never
they never said it they never mentioned
it no one inferred it and there was no
suggestion of it happening in that
series so it wasn't provable hims going
through this summary is proof of his
crime of what he orchestrated all the
things he did his explanation his motive
is in this dialogue here this is just
him saying exactly what he intended to
do like a like exactly properly executed
plans weren't exactly properly executed
I planned this that I'm saying
afterwards but he said before it didn't
go how I wanted to go and what he wanted
to happen like happened to only halfway
through yeah so all in the past but
that's all didn't
what matters now is moving forward and
all how beautiful the future is gonna be
with you I just love delivering these
lines can I talk about it just like say
that I love like know how beautiful
these the future is gonna be with you
like just having as soon as I went back
and I was like I decided on like the
singsong II hire kind of voice with a
lot of like low undertone effects like
just um like it really it breathed it
lived it moved it was so it was so
creepy like I hate the trope of like
video game villains and like super the
big baddies always being liked you wait
with Hannah what was what is my preset
here like I hate the trope of that being
like the case for all things because I
feel like there's so much play in like
different types of menacing and just
like I love that so come on you're
better than that
Oh what OH some people are saying like
um you sound like that idiot detective
it's just like cuz he does the detective
was screaming murder back in the mansion
- and who kill markiplier so just leave
me alone
you don't realize this place is a dream
a never-ending starring role is the hero
but what is it a hero with
a villain every good story needs a
villain you honestly think you're the
hero and all of this oh well of course I
am
who else could I possibly be my humble
upbringing my tragic backstory there's
no other role for me to play you're out
of your mind
oh you you are going to make the perfect
villain in my story so so what I wanted
to convey with this is like the same
thing I said about Celine like Celine
needed to have motivation to have like a
character to have like a drive I can't
just say that the actor wanted revenge
without painting the idea of what kind
of person the actor really is like he
he's in this world where he gets to play
out that the leading role of any story
he wants it's perfect it's beautiful
like he can't imagine other people not
loving that he can't he thinks he's
doing Damian a favor
cuz he's like you get to be part of my
story you're so lucky
can you believe out Allah and you'll be
great at it you you're going to be great
like that wait he didn't have an accent
like that but whatever like you're going
to be great yeah I kept like slipping in
it but just like he's a narcissist he's
just he's just a narcissist he's so much
an RCC so up his own ass
he can't even imagine that he's wrong I
have this I have this big like it's kind
of like evolved over time but I have
this belief that nobody is fully evil or
fully good like the whole concept of a
villain in a hero that's all just
stories that's that's not real life like
there aren't real villains and real
heroes there are just people some of
them who believe like are empathetic and
like can help other people but have
less selfish qualities and there's some
people that see everyone else as the
villain like the true villain is the one
that has the most enemies like it's it's
just like it when you see the world as
everyone's out to get ya like maybe
there's a reason why everyone doesn't
like ya and it's like it's it's just
this concept that like no one's truly
fully a hundred percent evil because
they're only pursuing what they think is
best for them but some people go about
it in a really dick way like a really
dick way and and so with the actor like
the reason he thinks he's the hero is
because from his perspective he is from
his perspective everyone else is the
villain in his story everyone else did
him wrong and and like if you if you put
yourself in issues and you look out and
you you get this warped narcissistic
sensibility about like imagine you were
as as self-absorbed as this like you
could see how he believes truly believes
that everyone else is out to get him and
so like this is what I wanted to like
convey with like his narcissism and his
his like demeanor and why he thinks he's
actually the hero that makes sense well
you can tell your story all you want to
the other prisoners oh come on
Damian let it go oh yeah yeah good point
mr. Rogers was sweetheart absolutely if
I lied there are heroes
then mr. Rogers one of them oh it's the
Rights Crusader pure as the driven snow
acting like you're the only one without
blood on your hands everything from me
wouldn't even have anything in the first
place if it wasn't for me took our lives
you betrayed me you betrayed William you
even betrayed serene well maybe if
Celine hasn't run off then we wouldn't
be here right now never good enough for
Celine I gave up but that's all in the
past so with my favorite sequence of the
entire [ __ ] thing like my favorite
the artist did so good oh hello oh thank
you so much thank you
perfect
Amy delivered painkillers I've been I've
been rock climbing a ton and my back has
been so so sore like I've got this big
ol knot in my back but Amy have you
brought me the sweet elixir of bane
killer there we go
big preach to Amy over there all right
so what I was oh yeah the animators like
just my absolute let me just put on me
for a sec just look my absolute favorite
part of this like cuz like you just
heard what I talked about his narcissism
before like this is his narcissism just
spilling over cuz he's like it's he is
saying like you wouldn't have anything
if it wasn't for me if Celine hadn't run
off instead of you know maybe we didn't
have a good relationship and you know
she like no she ran off Wilfred stole
her from me like this the first time
we're actually hearing this like cuz
this is things that I've talked about
before this is the first time he's
hearing this and just I love the [ __ ]
faces like this guy is so creepy
it's so creepy and you know like Damien
Damien's also getting pissed off cuz
he's like you're so stupid and just like
the way this is bent we wouldn't be here
right yeah
good enough for Celine I gave up and he
really thinks that he really thinks like
he really thinks he sacrificed
everything for her because and the
reason he says that is because his
career tanked after her left after she
left he gave her all these like this
this house the money he gave everything
for her and when she left he lost
everything so therefore it is her fault
like that's that's his that's his like
mindset that's his his idea bind it like
he's so in his own head about what what
happened here that he's just like he's
just this broken thing but he's he's
fine like he he's gracious because he's
willing to move on like that's what this
next parts about but that's all in the
past and now
I'm here to show you the future I don't
want anything to do with your future
disco drop dead and let me live my life
in peace I hate I hate this shot I hate
it I hate it cuz just it's just it's
just my mouth just way too close it's
not cuz I hate it paid so much I hate it
I hate it looking at it I just I hate
it's too close my friend what no matter
what tricks means feisty there's no
ending for the likes of us
what okay so him saying these words
Damien's Damien you know he's starting
to remember but he doesn't remember
everything and he definitely doesn't
understand anything that's kind of like
his shtick at this point you remember in
the void in the fourth episode of hukum
markiplier he's literally Davis is like
I don't know what the [ __ ] is going on
like that's it's kind of like the big
dumb softie it's just like he's a little
slow on the uptake so he literally
there's like leave me alone let me live
my life in peace and that's where that's
where actors just like oh yeah he's just
like he's just like Damon you don't man
you you're so far behind the times on
this cuz cuz Damien doesn't really
remember what the last few steps like he
doesn't remember losing his body he
doesn't remember any of this he he
doesn't realize that he's kind of dead
like he doesn't that's that's the point
of these the interstitials of like him
seeing his reflection as a Ronnie Christ
like it's uh it's just like all
reflections of who he is and like there
was I when I talked about how like I
wasn't a great writer in who killed
markiplier is like I wish I had trusted
my first instincts because the first
iteration I'll go ahead and tell you
this because it doesn't matter now
because it's not canon anymore even if
people would run from it but I'd rather
I'd rather get everything out on the
table in this one as opposed to hide
something later and just being like that
the riddle the original ending for
hookahs markiplier was not you the
Damien and Celine
take the viewers body the original
ending was still the actor steals
Damien's body but then Damien was was
gonna be forced to inhabit Marc's old
body the bro
the one that been stabbed 37 times the
stuff that all that happened that that
was the original ending and I rewrote it
and and I'm glad I rewrote it and I'm
not glad because I like the feel of the
current ending of who killed mark Blart
way more than I did the other ending
because I love the emotional even it was
so sad like the emotional moment that
wore sash had that was so like I loved
that so much and I liked that but it
also made a lot of problems like the fur
for like trying to figure out how to
write anything beyond that and answer a
question like it was it was it was one
of those things where the rule of cool
took over like what I wanted and it was
just like going to be it was gonna be
like it was a very much more emotional
and much more like impactful and it had
the ending was very very it had this
punch to the gut that I really needed at
that point especially like because when
I when I wrote who killed mark Blaire
and especially like in the month like
months after that I was in a really low
place and it's not that like I was in a
low place so I wanted to make others
suffer like that's not what it was but
it's just where my mindset was I wanted
that like I craved I crave this like
really really tragic ending to it and it
fit like it also wasn't one of those
things where I was it's like I'm sad so
I want it to be sad it's like it really
fit like it was really it was a
combination of a lot of elements and but
the original intention was that dark
applier was gonna be inhabiting the
actors old body and that's why he was
like like dead and you know this like
zombie kind of thing coming back to the
life but I'm telling you this just to
let you guys know that I'm not a perfect
storyteller I'm not a perfect writer not
everything has a nice tight bow wrapped
on it not everything is perfectly
executed and and when I'm saying that
I'm saying you don't need to make
everything fit to tell a decent story
you you also don't need to have
everything fit for people to appreciate
a story being told not everything has to
be perfect stories are just that they're
stories and so so when it comes down to
this and Damian being like
in this limbo state of purgatory of
death and not death being kept alive by
by his sister doing god-knows-what to
try to keep him alive like that's that's
really like where it's starting to come
to and it's wearing the like Damian's
starting to like get this realization
like and let's keep watching so I can
get more context to what I'm saying
what's the what what the [ __ ] really
what is the YouTube you did you really
oh my god YouTube [ __ ] up the
rendering they do this sometimes oh yeah
yep look they insert frames that are
that's you sack of [ __ ] you die just so
probably cuz I premiered it too [ __ ]
up the rendering of it whatever okay
whatever no one noticed it so they just
insert some frames that weren't supposed
to be there it's nothing okay before we
get to this really [ __ ] cool part
like then like I said before with the
it's time to wake up stuff like that
it's just like you know go back to sleep
it's time to wake up the actor wants
more characters in his story he wants
this villain like so and he knows like
maybe he doesn't know maybe it's just
like convenience of plot for the sake of
my own ego for writing but just like
this counterpoint of like go back to
sleep wake up this confusion of what
you're supposed to do it's kind of just
like so like representative of Damion
Lee not knowing what to people what are
people the people just keep telling me
what the [ __ ] to do when do I have a
choice in this you know people just keep
telling me I need to go to sleep you
need to wake up like what like when does
Damien get a choice in all this anyway
but this I love this part
ah sleeves so good so I [ __ ] love
that part because here's the reason I
love it for so long now people like the
the Wilfred and the actor have been like
man if Celine even saw me she would rip
my [ __ ] heart out and and just like I
really love the idea that Celine is just
a [ __ ] badass just like and this like
no hesitation just like you know it's
just like you get one moment and I
really wanted to like bring the the mood
to I I had this music like kick up just
like this is like Celine's music like
theme from who killed mark Bleier like
it's real calm it's just like no
hesitation just like you're like she
sees Target she kills Target like that
she's been looking for the actor for so
long she knows exactly what she was
gonna do like it's just like I just love
that so much and the way that they they
portrayed this the artists like
portrayed this just loved it
yeah I love it
I've organized just so and there's dumb
old David what the [ __ ] just happened
yeah
are you alright alright I've never been
less alright you need to explain to me
what the hell is going on there's no
time to explain
why does everyone keep telling me that I
spent God knows how long chopping down
trees with nothing but time on my side
and suddenly now there's no time I'm so
sick of being a pawn in other people's
games just give me a straight answer for
once so like there's there's a lot that
ton packin in this ending Anna and I
actually rewrote this entire ending um
originally it was gonna be much shorter
cuz I was I was worried about you know
it did getting too wordy and and too big
and I was trying to cut down time as
much as possible and I realized like the
ending like I couldn't just leave it on
this unknown note like this unknowable
note I mean it was a perfectly knowable
ending but it was just so short it just
didn't really give Damien a chance to
make a choice because I wanted it's so
important like I've been hammering about
like characters and like like what what
they what what they want their
motivations like Damien just wants to be
able to make a choice like he has had no
say in anything
his original like saying his motto his
part from hookah marklar of the three
characters in there was life is ours to
choose and he is not had a choice this
entire time like I couldn't leave it
with an ending that didn't give him a
choice and that's what this ending is so
like he literally is just saying like
I'm tired of people
yanking me around people [ __ ] with my
life you know and when he asked they're
like am i dead he wants to know he
doesn't like he's ready to face the
truth like it's one of those things
worse like you don't want to know the
answer but you have to know like he's
got a note this place doesn't make sense
like he's just been told by the actor
indirectly that he's dead he liked him
when when the fire goes out that's him
feeling like I wrote in a line that
before I rewrote it like pretty soon
after I initially wrote it those was
like I can't feel my heart that's him he
can't breathe he can't feel his
heartbeat that's that's what's implied
there is just he feels dead cold he
feels cold he feels dead like just
that's implied everything I've done I've
done to protect you
but I was too late too sloppy
he's undone everything now but he hasn't
won yet
Celine shut up you have no idea what I'm
capable of let me help you I remember
now I remember what he did what we did
man I all of that music so much I knew I
wanted to use it in the endings for both
Wilfred and Damian like I want I wanted
to use it I knew I did because I wanted
to carry on this this feeling you know
this this this like emotional connection
at the ending and with this one like I
like it was so beautiful I dropped it in
and with almost no rearrangement of the
music itself like it fit like I don't
know if I just write the exact same way
with all my endings like it's like but
it fit like perfectly just with that
moment where Celine says she's tired
like you Damian he sleeps at night
Celine has never slept this entire time
she is watching vigilantly like just
hunting vigilantly she is not resting
and just because she's such a
she's such a creature of such willpower
that she she's just like powering
through so so when when Damian's finally
asking like am i dead and she defiantly
says no like not on my watch and then
behind her like the walls cracking like
she knows the world the little sanctuary
that she made is crumbling like there's
too much damage to it like it's it's
breaking like this little hide hide away
this secret place that she made for
broken things is is breaking down and so
that's when she goes from the defiant
note to the defeated know and that's her
just being like slumping shoulders being
like I'm just so [ __ ] tired like
people and I've been in this place many
times like
I can keep up doing something for a long
time weeks in months I can keep going at
the same energy level and it'll it'll
just be that one small thing that just
breaks it for me that all the motivation
and all the willpower that I had just
melts away and a lot of that like that
came you know around who killed
markiplier when I when I took that break
for a month in October 2017 like I was I
just before it I was at this point in my
life where I was like trying to get a
lot work done I was really stressed I
was like I was getting a lot of sleep I
wasn't eating well you know but I was I
was working you know we were just about
to go on tour and I'm like okay I've got
a week to you know prepare for this I've
got a week and you know I'm I'm really
I'm really ready to do this I'll get
this and I remember I looked in the
mirror I think I've talked about this
once before but I looked in the mirror
and I just looked at myself and I looked
at myself for the first time in a long
time just looked at myself and I
realized that it was one of the first
times that I realized that I was getting
older you know I I saw gray hairs that
I've never seen before and it turns out
that a lot of those gray hairs were
stress gray hairs but you know I I saw
gray hairs you know I looked at my face
I was like you know I'm getting older
like and it was one of those things that
hit me that was like I've been working
myself to death that I haven't even
noticed that I've changed you know it
was just one of those moments where I
looked at myself in the mirror and hoses
late I didn't really recognize the
person staring back it wasn't just
because like I'd like wrinkles or no I'm
not I'm not that vain that I was like no
no wrinkles it was just one of those
things where was more just a realization
you know that time had passed that that
life was getting away from me and and it
took the wind right out of my sails like
just I was so motivated and I've been
working so hard and I was like okay I'm
gonna get so many videos recorded and
was just like instant like I couldn't it
was that big of a shift and and like
that's kind of
what what Celine's going through in this
place like a lot of what I writers just
like about personal experience and like
stuff like that but you know this is
just something that I think can really
be related to a lot of people you know
you can go hard for years and years and
years and you can you could be so ready
but then just that one thing of seeing
like you you're building your house of
cards and you spend you spend years
building this thing up and just like one
piece comes out and it all just comes
crashing down and then we look at that
you're just like but then I'm fine now
don't worry I'm fine now that was two
years ago I I mean I'm in such a good
place now I'm so happy like I've got
I've got so much cool stuff on the
horizon and I'll talk about that after I
get done with this for the reason why
I'm in Austin like that was two years
ago like I was in the I was in a bad
place but you know I I came out of it in
a healthy way because it led me down to
a lot of really creative things and it
pushed me to try to like focus on really
who I was and what's important in and
that's why you know the whole like
YouTube game just doesn't it doesn't
interest me anymore
not not that YouTube like playing
youtuber doing YouTube but the YouTube
game of chasing subscribers and chasing
[ __ ] like that the accolades and chili
that's in the end it's entirely
pointless what I love now is that I have
the ability to create and a lot of my
ability create comes directly from you
guys like you guys are allowing me to
make stuff that I really am happy to
make and I'm really excited to make a
project like Damian that just like make
me sit back like when I was done editing
Damian and I was like oh my god I think
I'm done like I sat back and I just like
cried like a [ __ ] like not not big
tears but I just like it was just like
it was so emotional that like it was
done you know nine months of work had
led to this moment where Damian was done
I was like holy [ __ ] it's done and I
couldn't believe it like I was so proud
like I was so proud of so proud of this
that we were able to do this together
that a team a professional game
development team wanted to help me make
something like this that Griffin
artists like you it was so emotional
like I'm in such a better place now like
don't get me wrong like I am absolutely
good but the reality of it is that like
a lot of a lot of like me coming to
terms with like Who I am is part of
realizing you know that you can never go
back you know you can never go back to
something you can never go back in time
to try to fix mistakes in the past you
can only try to move forward and try to
try to do them now but back to the story
like the actual story so Celine in this
moment she both both starts to defeat
but then it's like she picks herself
back up really quickly like she's like
she admits she almost admits defeat but
then she's like he hasn't won yet and
you know Damien being you know her
brother her younger brother he cares
very much about Celine he's he's very
protective about her there was there was
that line I didn't call back to it but
there's a line that they both have that
they share from who killed markiplier
which is like just be careful and so I
can take care of myself or I believe her
line is just like I don't need help at
least of all from you this is like more
like same thing different words but
Damon you know he cares but his sister
and you know he remembers everything
that's that's the point of those lines
like and that's why the music gets like
intense again because she's just like
she's going down the past this is like
he sees her going down a path that if
she keeps going down it she will never
come out of it very similar into the way
of the detective like he could go down
that path of obsession forever and if if
worse - did nothing maybe he would never
have been able to break out of that and
this is the same thing with Damien like
he wants to help that's why this this I
love this moment
you can't keep this
shut up you have no idea what I'm
capable of let me help you I remember
now I remember what he did what we did
Damian you have no idea what's really
going on here you're right I haven't got
a clue but I know that even you can
protect me forever
so so this is like an important moment
for for Damian because he he's making a
choice like he doesn't know the details
of what's going on he doesn't know
exactly what's up but you know he trusts
that Saleem is trying to do the best for
him and he knows that whatever she's
doing whatever her motives are at the
end of the day she is his sister and he
wants to help whether or not that means
you know things will change for him like
he wants to help like that's that's what
happens you know in these situations if
I had to boil Damian down to one big
like moral or whatever I would say this
is a story about coming to terms with
the things that life throws at you this
is about someone who didn't choose to
have things happen to and and no one
ever does no one ever chooses what life
throws at you no one ever chooses what
kicks you while you're down no one ever
chooses to to suffer and go through loss
and pain and tragedy but you know in my
mind it's not about what happens to you
it's about how you respond to that pain
like I said it's about how you respond
afterwards it's about the choices that
you make when that happens and it might
not always work out for the best no I
know
be perfect but those choices that you
make define who you are as a person and
Damien you know he's been kicked around
he's been dragged around he hasn't had a
choice things have happened to him that
he doesn't understand but at the end of
the at the end of it all he makes a
choice that even if he doesn't
understand he knows that his sister
can't do this alone period and that's
all that matters to him he's gonna help
and he wants to help so like that's a
that's a big philosophy of my life the
things I do it's not just about
protecting you everything's different
now the mistakes I've made the people
I've used the things I've had to do to
keep you alive some things just can't be
fixed and I'm okay with that but if you
let me help you then maybe I just want
I'm pausing it right there because I
love the way the music this is the exact
same piece of music the exact same
there's no change to it but the moment
that like Damien starts to smile here
suddenly in my mind when I was playing
through it it wasn't so sad cuz cuz de
meanie he said some things can't be
fixed
Damien knows he can never go back to
what he had before he can never go back
to the life that he had and he's okay
with that and like that's just I I love
that mindset and even if I as a person
am writing something that I can't always
fulfill like I love that this character
can make this choice to not just not not
even like look at the bright side but
just realize that there's nothing that
you can do to go back and fix the
mistakes of the path the only thing that
you can do is move forward from that
point and that's what he's saying here
like like he's okay
that Celine tried to fix but trying to
fix him is gonna get her killed and he's
okay with what happened to him he's not
happy about it no I don't think anybody
would be but you know it's okay and then
just like I love this piece of music cuz
like as soon as he makes his choice like
it stops being a sad piece like here
right let me help you then maybe
together we can start to set things
right you can really feel the the kind
of hope out of it it's you look tired
I think you need to get some sleep
you can't remember the last time I slept
don't worry you can't come back from
this it'll change you forever well he
did say he wanted me to be the villain
maybe he should be more careful as his
wishes
just promise me one thing make sure
[Music]
I [ __ ] love it I love it so much
I and I know I'm talking about something
that like I wrote so this is really like
vapid of me to say but just just to see
the art come together with the music and
like the acting from Pam and just like
all that like I love it so much like
with Wilfred mother little more sex like
I love that Mick puts so much emotion
into like that last moment at the end
and like with the music and it's a
dramatic piece like a music and and and
it's it's yeah and I'm never gonna use
it again I like I I know I'm never ever
gonna use it again because it lives in
the world of who killed markiplier and
and it just represents this ending this
like this resolution this sad resolution
this bittersweet moment of emotion and
like I just love this ending so much and
and like I said it worked perfectly
I didn't this this moment this moment I
didn't time that out that is just how
that music ended all I did was ramp up
the volume of it when it happened like
that that was it a few a few notes just
for story beat like Damian is what
Damian is doing in here is he's taking
his turn basically he's he's uh because
this whole time Celine's been doing it
all herself Selena's boom everything
herself she's been like like protecting
Damian like going out trying to find the
actor like keeping this world safe like
all the all the stuff all by herself and
so he's taking he's offering help and
basically saying like I'm gonna do it
and she's like I don't remember the last
time I slept it's because she hasn't and
she's just very tired and then you know
he was like maybe careful he wishes you
know she says this will change you
forever like it's like he's just
resolving that and make sure that
bastard stays dead it's just like you
know this is a good final note and on
the clarification Celine is not dead
like how in this entire conversation
some people are like I can't believe
singing is dead now and I'm like what
wait what weird
what and I'm just like I guess people
looked at this moment or like though
she's dead she drowned in the water that
is definitely real and it's just like
you see a house with a giant wall
cracking in and you're like that's real
it's real it's real water it's deadly
it's just like this is this is a place
of the mind it's not not necessarily I
mean I can get out people would think
that whistling is not dead she's
sleeping it was actually I wanted to I
wanted to have a little like ending
moment I I changed my mind to have this
the ending that's at the end the jump
scary ending because originally one
ending where Worf stache comes in and
it's just like it's like total cut to
black and then works out comes I'm like
oh there you are Damien I've been
looking all over for you and then like
like Damon's like oh I will or whatever
he [ __ ] does and then Wolfe was like
something like like you haven't seen
sleep around anyone how are you
if I can avoid her I'd rather do it and
then day me it would be like she's
sleeping and then Wilfred would be like
like don't good oh good great all right
well anyway glad I found you I I got a
great new idea we're gonna make a TV
show and like there's gonna be this long
pause before dark went okay cut to
marklar TV somebody was so that was that
was what was gonna be so that that's
canon just imagine that is immediately
after this that is that is immediately
after this market Blair TV isn't me it
goes who killed markiplier Wolfer dwarf
slash Damien Marga Laura TV but I you
know I figured like it was it was such a
drastic theme change
wish I did it but you know I'm happy
with the wit and now but that is what I
wanted to happen at the end because one
like one of the big things that I I'm
happy that this is all done because the
story of who killed markiplier it's a
very bittersweet story because it had to
be and even though I didn't write it
perfectly then and it wasn't just me
writing it like we wrote it together I
don't want to take all the credit or all
the blame like I don't want to pay all
the credit for like writing it but also
just like it was a collaborative effort
but you know like that that was what it
had to be and these stories resolved
them because you know they they answer
the questions then they give the
characters the proper motivation and
they get characters from where they were
to where they need to be that was the
point of Wilfred Lovett mother-loving
war sash in addition to was some other
ideas behind it it was a vehicle to get
characters from A to B and that's all I
really wanted to accomplish but well at
the end of the Wilfred explanation I
said that you know I was um I I said
that I was um one second that I said
that I you know didn't want to answer
all the questions is because I I wanted
to leave some things open for people to
interpret but I'm not gonna do that this
time
I'm going to give very explicit reasons
for why this is the way it is but before
I do that and really like blow your
minds with the magic of my genius once
again thank you for just all the members
that have supported this without you
this would never have been made without
you will for mother living war sex would
never have been made and without you the
next projects that I'm going to be
working on that I'm currently working on
would not be possible literally I mean
that they would not be possible without
you and your support so just seriously
thank you guys and if you are not a
member and you want to help me make
great stuff please consider being a
member hit that join button we have
weekly live streams that we talk about
almost every week there's
behind-the-scenes stuff that I post for
the members in the community page
there's tons of sneak peeks that I want
to offer you
I actually showed the members this is
I'm so proud of the members for like
keeping it a secret I showed them a
sneak peek of Damien a month ago no one
leaked did no one said anything about it
like it's like it's so great that you
guys are there supportive and just so so
cool so thank you and if you would like
to be a member please consider it there
are some perks that you get and you can
do it by hitting that joint button right
down there so I wrote these down because
I didn't want to didn't want to
basically I didn't want to lose track of
it so the whole big overarching story
overarching meaning whatever whatever it
is whatever you want to say whatever it
could be the whole overarching story is
that these are stories pure and simple
literally like I I'm not even just
saying that just to be like oh they're
just made up [ __ ] stories no in this
universe the world that they live in
after the events of who killed
markiplier are that they are in stories
they are they're acting out you know
scripts they are acting out these videos
they're doing these things because they
are characters in stories the detective
in Wolford mother-loving lore says some
people got this you know but not
everyone believed it because it was
probably too simple and they're like it
can't be that's got to be convoluted no
it's very simple the detective is who
the detective is because he's a
detective so therefore he's going to be
the detective in every story throughout
some people were pointing to the Train
you know when horses like all the train
how long was stuck in the snow for that
is just a reference to
Murder on the Orient Express or whatever
it was it's it's not saying that you
know it doesn't matter like what he said
it matters why he said that thing like
what I said before he's mentioning that
because on that train in that story
there is a detective and there's a
character that theoretically Worf stash
could play in that story the detective
plays out the role of whatever he needs
to fill because he's the detective much
like the actor wanted Damian to be the
villain he wants people to slot into
these roles in the story and act them
out and be these characters and with
with with saline and and and Damian they
live in this place because Saleem made a
little pocket story of her own she made
up this narrative she made up just
enough so that Damian wouldn't question
it and would keep going out into the
world get firewood but there's firewood
already like that's why he said those
things but we already have firewood and
I needed to get back home you know he
doesn't realize these things just like
the detective doesn't realize that why
does he know like why does he know that
he needs to hunt him down why does he
know that oh we had a close call in
Bermuda because we and you and when you
he knows that because in the script his
character knows that someone [ __ ] this
is not about the host or the author like
don't don't get this confused with that
that's not what this is about but just
as an as an metaphor or simile or
allegory like whatever imagine if
someone if you had a character like the
detective and his character traits were
hunts Wharf stash has had many
encounters with Dwarfs - like was very
close to catching him on numerous
occasions but he always managed to slip
away that's literally the opening
dialogue of wilfred mother-loving morse
- every time I got close but he always
managed to slip away
that is the preface of a story but that
does not mean that you
lived that characters life and that's
why the detective falls short on all of
that dialogue because every time he's
asked more details about it which Worf
stash is asking him outside of this
script he's asking him because war sesh
doesn't exist and like he's not
following the rules of the story he's
breaking the rules of the story
continuity doesn't make sense because
he's not playing his role correctly he's
just having fun in this weird
imagination world you know he's doing
this stuff the detective is just trying
to still stick to his role he doesn't
understand that he's not part of that so
that's why you know he it doesn't make
sense for him and the wharfs s breaks
the detective out of that and and like
that was the whole concept of wilfred
mother-loving worse - in in this one
with damien celine there there exist in
this little little dream world of non
reality like there this isn't real no no
none of that's real nothing happening
there is real and like this this this
kind of idea that there's heroes and
villains like that's all just what the
actor wants that's all he wants he just
wants to live out stories he wants to
play roles he wants to play pretend play
imagination he wants to go into this
world and like have this great time
playing all these different roles and
and that's an allegory to all that's a
that's a metaphor for all the videos on
my channel that's all it is
it is justification for my channel to be
what it is and for me as real me to play
all these roles like the truth of it is
the house is just an analogy for my head
like this is just my imagination
and all these characters in it are
characters that I've written and funny
only enough it is canon that there are
plot holes because I'm not the perfect
writer I've made the perfect out for me
see I'm a genius see if there are
potholes the things don't make sense
because I made them up wrong everything
is [ __ ] in my
all you guys are seeing are little
snippets of these characters in my head
that is literally how I wrote these
things the house is my mind the actor
Damian and Worf stache are like three
facets of my personality Damian is the
empathetic part the caring part the the
one that really wants to help the one
that wants to go out there and do things
Worf stache is the insane part the the
the the zany part the the one that
doesn't always make sense the one that
says things that he doesn't mean that
the the part that's goofy that tries to
have fun all the time the actors is the
part of me that's kind of narcissistic
the the [ __ ] part of me like it's
it's these are all just like pieces of
myself as I've always said with my
channel my channel is just a
representative of who I am and what
things are coming across so with who
killed markiplier like that's that's
really what it is and of course they eat
like you could give blood then whose
saline and lose that part of your brain
ass like it's a story and thankfully I
can finally say that that's just the
justification for it like it is a story
it is all funny make them ups in my head
and that's how I've made it so so but
just to get more specific in and
actually care about the story is um like
in universe in in this universe where
hypothetically all this is happening in
in a place called the mansion that is a
representative my head these these
characters act out their lives in in my
head and they're transformed in in in a
way where time doesn't necessarily make
sense because as first timeline goes I
imagined when I first wanted this to
happen I imagined in that one moment and
a lot of people guess this and that one
moment where the hand in who killed mark
lotta reaches out for the cane I
imagined like an eternity hanging in
just a single second like if in that
moment time froze and all of the events
of Damien happened in that one moment
like just that one moment hanging in
time
that's when it all happened because I've
said forever like time doesn't make
sense especially in your mind like the
order of events doesn't always make
sense things happening don't make sense
and if if that can all hang in that one
moment it can all take pale take place
right then and there it's like that's
what it is
no see Wow god I see it already saline
is the protector archetype it's like no
these not all the characters are a part
of my personality the only things that
I'm saying is those three are
representative of Who I am probably cuz
I play them and I think that's really
poetic and nice the other characters
let's just say let's just say fur
because people want this let's say that
those are before before they went in the
mansion they were real people with real
lives and they had their own dreams and
ambitions but once they went in the
mansion they became trapped there they
were trapped inside the mind of some
other me like they were trapped in my
mind and that's kind of like what that's
all about
so don't worry about trying to apply
every single one of the characters to a
facet of my personality I mean do it if
you want I don't care it's not right but
like whatever it's um it's it's just the
fact that I love to tell stories and I
didn't want this who killed mark blurred
thing to become the defining moment of
my entire channel and I don't think it
is I don't think it is I think that's
still five nice Andy yeah but it's uh
it's no it's not like the movie split
stop stop stop
it's not like the movie split mmm that's
not what is that's not what it is at all
see you see I knew when ever see that's
what the problem with explanations is
people will take everything I'm saying
absolutely literally and like it's it's
gospel and they'll try to apply to other
characteristics that's not what it is
that's not what it is at all cuz it's
just a story
and it's just a story at the end of the
day so there's one more question that I
know you guys will ask and that's where
is the viewer in all of this and if you
think about it in terms of what I just
said and understand the motif of the
viewer being an observer of this story
you're right there right exactly where
you are behind the glass
cuz right now you're watching this
behind glass of your phone or your
laptop of a computer like the analogy is
simply that link that's all it is
I like the first-person storytelling
element of it I like that about that and
the whole concept of like you know being
trapped in the mirror and stuff like
that it's very nice and it's very poetic
it's very cool but a lot of what I was
trying to get at is the viewer isn't not
just you playing it out the viewer is
literally you from that moment on of who
kill marklar after the events of that
you guys are literally watching
everything unfold the stories that play
out inside of this universe you are
forced to be an observer of it never
actually being able to change anything
never being able to do anything just
watching and like that that's kind of
just like what what it was all about and
so I I imagined this this you know it
seems really really depressing from the
end of who killed marklar and that's why
I wanted to write these two stories to
let it open up open up into the universe
that we know because like I don't I like
writing like dramatic [ __ ] and stuff
like that but I also like writing really
fun [ __ ] and that's the point
of like my channel it's not it's not -
it's not to make everything really like
down in the dumps about everything it's
it's about fun like what we do here and
the videos that we make they're fun like
there's fun [ __ ] and and like that's
that's why I say can
Nanakuli the immediately next event from
this is who is markiplier TV because
markiplier TV is a [ __ ] fun
experience it is fun it doesn't have to
be sad that you guys are watching things
from now on because if everything is fun
like if everything is really cool and
fun that's what makes it a great
experience and so in in the universe
like obviously like the story is what
the story is but the beautiful thing is
is you aren't trapped in there with them
you're not stuck in with these
characters these little pieces of
imagination in these worlds you are just
watching that's cool and it's uh pretty
cool and also you guys are helping so
that's awfully nice of you guys so
anyway yeah that's Wilfred talking oh my
god you're still doing it you're still
doing it ah that's the Wilfred mu
talking oh that's the Damien in your
talking isn't it oh you're being sassy
is that the actor talking like good god
my god that's the worst thing that is
there's just absolutely terrible you
should feel ashamed of yourself
yeah anyway so basically I think that
wrapped up everything I think I got
everything on my list that I wanted to
talk about yep
that's pretty much it I think I got
through everything yeah so that explains
all of Damien that explains all of my
mindset behind this stuff so yeah it's
pretty good it's the stand a me no it's
not Stan Stan talking at all
so also the reason that I'm I'm I'm
giving this in such detail is also
because there's a lot more stuff that I
want to do and I don't want it to all be
so goddamn dramatic the the project that
I'm working on right now is going to be
so fun it's so it's just pure fun like
that's the thing and that's the thing
that I want to do and that's why I want
I wanted to wrap up the story of hookah
market boy I wanted to wrap it up how
does a date with markiplier fit into
this
it doesn't like don't worry about that
that doesn't fit in period cuz cuz like
everything that happens after who killed
markiplier so it's who killed markiplier
is the beginning it's the five nights at
freddy's 2 of it all whatever it's like
who killed markiplier wilfer brother
looking more fresh Damian and then
everything after that is fun like it
just gets fun because it's a world of
imagination where everybody gets
something everybody accepts what happens
like that that's the big moral of it
like a I really do don't think that this
is me being like I don't take Damian
seriously or I don't take the story
behind it seriously because I very much
do never make that mistake because I
really do care about the the dramatic
Ness of it I I care that things exist as
the way they should be as the way they
deserve to be and that doesn't mean that
just because I want things to be fun
after that doesn't mean that I'm never
going to make something dramatic or
series again or I'm never going to like
give things the gravitas that it needs
that is essential to like what I want to
showcase in what I do and with these
stories like the moral is just accepting
the [ __ ] that life throws at you not
accepting it gladly like just and just
being like oh yeah more please but just
accepting that life much like this this
weird place that they're in like it's
it's indeterminate it's it's
non-judgmental but it can be cruel and
it can be horrible and it can beat you
down and it can be completely unfair
like it's it's not fair like is
sometimes life just isn't fair and the
way that people can react to it really
describes who they are like the actor he
spiraled downward because he could not
accept the idea that life had thrown him
the cards that they did they he couldn't
accept that his wife left him that that
that he lost the rules because he did
anything wrong that he that like he was
spiraling out of control he lost his
friends he could
except that so his choice was to create
a situation that tore his entire
friendship and the people that cared
about him apart he killed he he
destroyed lives he did terrible things
all because that was his choice and how
he responded after life dealt him that
card with wharfs - he may have made
mistakes he was not a perfect person but
he was thrown in his situation where
this former friend of his contrived a
situation that took everything away from
him and his justification was madness he
things didn't make sense for him and
rightly so because the universe didn't
make sense anymore so his choice was to
roll with it to enjoy things while
they're there the temporary nature of
life is why it's so precious you know
what you have and when you have it is so
essential to appreciate and that's all
worth - does he lives in the now he
lives in the moment and that can make
you do some really weird things and
really [ __ ] up choices especially as I
start to spiral downwards but that's the
embodiment of that choice with Damian he
had no choice of what was happening he
didn't understand why he couldn't
contemplate why his friends were tearing
themselves apart why mark was dead why
horses didn't care why where Wilfred
didn't care and why why all these things
were happening why his sister was
suddenly here again trying to do some
weird things with the occult that he
didn't understand and he was robbed and
and he had things stolen from him and at
the end of it all he's just the kind of
person that wants to help and of course
he wants revenge he's angry like he was
angry at mark he really was and like he
wants to take revenge back but the point
is like the choices that led him to
where he was are choices that help the
people that he cares about that's at the
end of the day
and I said a long time ago that dark
applier was the opposite of me this
narcissistic [ __ ] that was just this
terrible person that could never ever
like be beloved would manipulative was
this awful person and I ask you has dark
applier ever been named in any of my
videos who is the person who is the
character in this universe that is the
opposite of me a narcissistic [ __ ]
who would use the people around him at
any given turn like do anything to get
ahead in life who is the person in these
videos that is the real dark applier
anyway so what am i doing in Austin I am
making a new series I am I am making a
wonderful wonderful interactive story a
wonderful wonderful wonderful
interactive story where I'm going to
basically take you guys on an incredible
adventure I can't say anything about it
but what I can say is that this is going
to be the biggest project that I've made
thus far I know I have not been great on
videos lately and that's gonna change
because after this I'm planning to
record some stuff and I've got lick sea
and helping me out with some other stuff
and I I really really really want to get
back on the swing of things because like
I said before I want to make fun things
I want to really push the envelope of
what people can expect out of YouTube
and and what's really cool is like and
what's so cool is like with this Demian
thing I know people have like made stuff
like this before and they put it out on
YouTube but it's just like the fact that
I can do it with a story that like I
just made up
the top of my head and then you guys
support it is just so really cool and
with this next project like I'm working
with so many talented people with a real
production company on making something
super fun it's just like it's so
unbelievably cool it's so cool
it's so really really cool to people to
do this kind of stuff and just like yeah
I just I want to do things that make me
happy and make me excited and I'm doing
that like I'm doing it I get to do it
every day and that's just like the
coolest thing ever so I got no other
words besides cool to say about it but
yeah just thank you guys so much now I'm
gonna be filming here for probably three
to four weeks depending on how shooting
goes it's good the longest shoot that
I've ever had and yeah it'll be cool it
probably won't be out for many many
months don't expect this to be like
around the corner so I'm gonna be in
Austin for like another month or so and
then I'm gonna be heading out back to LA
once we're all done here and then
there's a lot of post-production stuff
and then yeah back to normal videos at
some point in the future I was also in
Cincinnati yesterday good god that was
just in Cincinnati I was I was in
Cincinnati yesterday because I was at
pivot in Kings Island let me tell you
something i-i-i-i was that I was at
Kings Island back when I was like
starting at five years old Kings Island
is a theme park oh let me let me do
something now that we're done talking
about Damian I want to do something real
quick seriously thank you guys so much
and thank you for humoring me with
speaking with the the members during
this I just wanted to give them a
special moment because they helped make
this a reality so I wanted to have that
but I'm going to unleash the masses
what the hell what what what what what
what
what's happening whoa what's happening
oh no oh oh no what's happening Oh
what's happening are you two broke it's
my channel still there guys am I still
here what is happening oh my god okay
all right here we go
wait okay I'm back in it all right cool
I'm back I guess I'm back hey how's it
going guys I'm back baby I'm back I'm on
a roll back baby baby I'm back I'm out
of control I'm back baby
all right and here we go there we go
there we go and wobbu ski wobbu ski habu
ski there we go you're free there we go
okay perfect got it good good good
okay so yeah I was in I was in
Cincinnati
hi everybody hey guys hello hi how you
doing
we've been set free yeah yeah there we
go there we go yeah so um I I don't
think before I before I finish this
thought about things like one of the big
one of the big things that I I I really
love about what I do and wanted me
to do is like I'm able to do things
without taking it too seriously and
that's like a big big part of what I do
there are some things that I really want
to take seriously like who killed mark
Blair Damien and will for one more
session I take very seriously but even
in them I don't take them that seriously
I write things just because they sound
cool or they're fun or there's things
like that and this next project that
I've got going on in Austin is the
embodiment of that it is just it's just
it's just me not taking things so
seriously it's it's it's the loveliness
that comes out of what YouTube is and
what YouTube can represent so it's just
so cool I love it I love it
I love so much but anyway I was in
Cincinnati yesterday yeah I know I'm in
Austin and I flew at Cincinnati for one
day for pivot which is a eSports
convention preview that they had in in
Kings Island and I don't know if you
guys saw the livestream but we did a
little panel there a small mean greed
but pivot Thank You Jesse Joffrey thank
you thank you rad man Chris I know there
were so many people super chatting and
becoming members and I wasn't reading it
but just thank you guys so much for
being here I just wanted to have all the
discussion all in one good chunk there
and leave that as it is but uh with
being in Kings out I was there when I
was like five years old certified and
when we went pretty much every summer
since I was five years old all the way
up until I was like 17 that's a long
time to see the park from within and
like see like how its evolved over time
and things have changed inside of it and
yesterday I was behind the scenes of
Kings Island I never imagined that I
would ever be behind the scenes of Kings
Island like I met the the VP Thank You
Melissa I I meant the VP there I met the
people that like run see there's fair
eye I met a lot of cool people thank you
red panda and cozy wolf thank you and
then just like all this cool stuff that
III remembered seeing as a child then I
was seeing from this high vantage point
like I was in a knife
we tower or like look I was like one
floor up but there was a nice banquet I
didn't know thank you parent and Phoenix
right and it's just like oh okay believe
it look it's the Eiffel Tower yeah
there's the Eiffel Tower Kings Island
and Thank You crystal and this is like
oh thank you I am trash number one it's
just like an amazing thing and just
these so many people showed up to this
end so many people were all there it was
so funny because there were people there
like hey Jade
oh God Thank You demon thank you okay
Thank You Rachel they no stop Thank You
Oliver
thank you but we were like blocking the
line for the Banshee which is one of the
main rollercoasters with our line and so
there are some people that were like oh
man we didn't get into the meeting so I
was like who is this goddamn [ __ ]
blocking me from getting in this ride
it's like this is a nice 50/50 mixture
of that and so we were in his tent and
people were just like pressing it like
totally open to the public so people are
just faces up against the plastic
sheeting of this weird little tent that
I'd like open views of everything and we
were just like in there like it was a
zoo people were just like looking at and
being like wow there there there is
there is what the phone's up smashed up
against the tents and we're just like
thank you anyway but ya know it's pretty
cool I like that a lot yeah so I think
that wraps up pretty much everything I
gotta get to recording some videos I
have to tomorrow we start filming so
good god okay we got to do that I did
make a who killed markiplier playlist I
did do that I did do that so I'm gonna
get out of here I've got work to do
thank everybody so much for watching I'm
gonna try to write the timestamps of the
various discussion points but I didn't
hit any of my notes on my frickin note
sheet so that's there anyway
yeah whatever but yeah I'm gonna get
there and yeah it's gonna be it's gonna
be pretty cool yeah it's pretty cool
yeah I'm excited
I'm excited about I'm excited about the
future there's a lot of cool things that
are coming to buy and yeah it's gonna be
cool oh yeah get ready for a gym back
story that'll be the next thing a really
sad somber tale about how gym was thrown
into a cloning machine and and and just
like used to spendable soldiers in a
some super soldiers so sad
Jim will have to kill Jim and then Jim
will have to kill Jim as revenge for
killing Jim it's gonna be so sad you're
gonna you're gonna hate it you're gonna
hate it it's gonna be so sad it's a bug
yeah so get ready for the tearful tragic
backstory of of Jim just just imagine
wait hang on I want I want you to I want
you to really feel this and literally I
really want you to feel this yeah wait
Jim I can't feel the cold anymore Jim
what are you talking about it it's it's
not cold at all what Jim but it feels so
cold but my heart I I don't know how
much more I can go on tell me I'm gonna
be okay how do I look at my legs working
Jim you know you don't have legs anymore
they got blown off
by their land mine oh damn well if I'm
not gonna make it you got take this back
to our mother Jim Jim no don't don't
leave me Jim Jim just remember what our
Father Jim told us what you don't mean
son Jim and other sons you I love you
I'll always remember you Jim
Sam it's too loud Jim I can't hear you
Jim you go he's gonna remember what your
mother didn't toast you what are you
dying to dad yeah I'm on my deathbed I
told you this all my deathbed I mean why
I'm telling you this but I do this
anyway your mother Jim who died
tragically she was actually three
different Jim's embodying one Jim
imagine if the worst side of three
separate Jim coins were shoved into some
kind of Jim triangle that's that's what
your mother Jim was and tore her apart
she's evil she's the embodiment of all
the opposite of Jim's dad dad Jim I
can't really believe that you'd be
telling us about our mother that we
loved on your deathbed
well the truths gotta come out sometime
[ __ ] just gotta live with it
listen dad Jim don't play no [ __ ] and
you gotta listen anyway listen shut up
it's not like that at all I loved triple
Jim mother Jim just as much as I could
any boy even though she was main and
horrible and horribly murderous I kept
making fan art of her about her being a
sweetheart and you know she wasn't like
that in real life but she was like that
in my heart and so I just believed and
if I believed hard enough and if I made
enough fan fiction and fantasy me I
would convince the original creator of
Jim to turn that triple Jim and just
some kind of delightful daddy bear of a
Jim dad dad Hodgins if this flashback is
over now oh yeah I'm dying no legs
dad that's what my dad told me Jim Jim
oh it's all true but just remembering
was that Jim the real Jim
all right there you go MC sorry about
that anyway all right so that's all I've
got for now thank you everybody so much
expect videos to return hopefully
starting tomorrow hopefully and if not
then run me out of town with pitchforks
and stuff I'm gonna be working hard on a
new project I'm gonna try to give you
some cool sneak peeks and stuff to see
but if I can't share it that is all I
got so thank you so much for watching
thank you for joining me for this wild
ride of an explanation and take care of
yourselves one and all thank you so much
expect new videos starting tomorrow
we've got one more markiplier makes for
you that we pre-recorded for a while ago
so thank you so much and as always I'll
see you in the next video bye bye